- I really just
worry about Google
being able to swing an election.
At least when Facebook
rips the Hunter Biden story
off the internet two or three
weeks before the election.
- Mm-hmm.
- Which is complete crap,
and they shouldn't
be allowed to do it,
but when they did
that, people noticed,
and you have the Streisand
effect sort of thing,
where it's this discussion.
- Right.
- We can talk about it
and at least the
censorship was transparent,
but with Google, they can change
their search algorithms to,
if they're subtle enough,
I think you could change
it a meaningful amount,
suppress this
information about Trump,
and boost this
information about Biden,
and all of a sudden,
do you really live in
a free country anymore?
(dramatic ambient music)
- All right, we are in studio,
and joining me today is
the COO of Thiel Capital,
the co-author of, "Zero to One,"
which I keep on the set
normally, right over there.
And the next Senator
from the great state of
Arizona, Blake Masters!
- Yeah.
- Welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Thank you, it's
great to be here.
- I'm glad to have you man,
I've wanted to do
this for a while.
We wanted to do it in person.
- Yes.
- As I said, you are the
co-author of that book,
which I think was really
one of the sort of
formative things for me
to get involved in the tech
world, and all of that.
And I know that's
obviously something
that interests you a lot,
so why don't we start there?
How'd you start
working with Thiel,
and getting some of
these ideas across
about making new things?
- Yeah well, I was a student
at Stanford Law School,
and I remember my friend
said, "Hey, Peter Thiel,
you know, the founder of
PayPal, was gonna teach a class
and so we should
take that class."
And I didn't know that
much about Peter then,
I knew he was
libertarian, businessman,
billionaire, founded
PayPal, that seemed cool.
- Good recipe.
- So he was into seasteading,
You know.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- This idea that you should
maybe think about how
to start new countries.
- We should get
back on that idea actually.
- We'll talk about that.
So he seemed like a
cool guy and you know,
what an opportunity to
take a class from someone
who wasn't just a professor,
you know, actually done
something in the world.
So I took,
hey, I took that class and
sort of befriended Peter.
This is my second
year in law school,
went to go intern for him
at his venture capital fund
that summer, and then he came
back taught another class,
my last year in law school,
I took really good
notes on that class.
I just basically typed
down everything he said,
'cause I liked the first class,
but I can't tell you
too much about it,
'cause it's all lost to memory,
right.
- Right.
- I wasn't like a big
note taker in college,
'cause who cares?
But the second time
I was prepared,
so I wrote down
everything Peter said,
cleaned it up, posted it online.
And these notes became
kind of like a phenomenon
in Silicon Valley.
- Uh.
- This was like 2012.
'Cause I think it
was the first time
you could actually kind of
collect all of Peter's thoughts
on building a startup, that's
what the class was about,
startups and
technology companies
and how to do new things
in a stagnant society.
And so I think people
who were interested
in Peter at the time
and his stock was
sort of rising,
like Facebook was
just about to IPO,
you could piece together
things from like interviews,
print interviews, YouTube, but
there was no one set of like
here's Peter Thiel's thoughts
on how to start a startup.
And all of a sudden me is
this random Stanford student,
was publishing this online.
And so Silicon valley,
a couple 1000 people
just started following
week over week these notes
and became this
really successful.
- Oh, so you were
doing it in real time?
You were in the class.
- I was doing it in real time.
- Putting the notes up
and people were following.
- Real time.
- So basically they were
getting the education for free.
- That's right.
- Along side you,
yeah.
- Yeah.
Which is really interesting
'cause it was this
awesome class,
and you know, I
think we ultimately,
we turned it into a
very successful book,
but I think it
would've just died,
like all the material and
like Peter worked hard
to organize all the
thinking for the class,
but if it's not recorded,
if it doesn't actually
get outside the classroom,
it just dies there.
And that would've
been a big shame.
- Yeah.
So the basic premise
of the book is that
the next Facebook is not
going to be Facebook,
to go from zero to one, you
have to do something fully new.
- Right.
- Does that feel more sort of
relevant now than it did even,
eight, 10 years ago because
of the sort of upheaval
and weird spot that
we're in right now?
- It does.
I think we desperately
do need new technology
to sort of take things
to the next level.
We have a remarkably
stagnant society.
I think people get distracted,
like the iPhone 13
Pro just came out.
It's like, congratulations,
the camera's much better.
And that's cool.
- Wait, is a half inch bigger
or smaller?
- Half inch bigger at school,
I'm literally.
- Bigger, better now.
- It's good enough,
we literally just shot a
campaign ad in cinema mode
on iPhone 13 pro,
and I was like.
- Oh, wow.
- Holy shit, this is actually
a really good camera.
So there's some innovation,
but it's also marginal.
- Mm-hmm.
- And this is all confined
to sort of your smartphone
or sort of IT broadly
or software startups,
actually society looks so
much like it did in the 1970s,
like we're not moving faster,
in some ways we're
moving slower.
You know, we don't
build houses any better
or more efficiently now.
Actually housing prices are
just going through the roof,
right, so, so much in
our society is stagnant
and Zero to One is yeah,
narrowly a business book,
but broadly it's the sort of
exploration of why is so much
of our society just stagnant,
like why can't we do new things?
- Is that kind of the core
of why you wanna
go into politics?
Or is it fair to say you
even wanna go into politics
in a way or were you being
sort of dragged to politics?
I sense that with a
lot of people that
are getting involved,
it was like, I didn't really
wanna be a politician at first,
but somebody's got to fix this.
- Somebody's gotta fix this,
yeah.
- And I'm somebody?
- I definitely have
that view of it.
I mean, I'm getting into it,
I really wanna get into
it, I think it's important.
You know, I'm loving
campaigning, I'm
gonna win the race.
So on Monday.
- You just told everybody.
- You just told everyone,
so that's gonna happen.
- You're right, you're golden.
- But it'd be nice in some
sense, like if I didn't have to,
like, if things were working,
if we didn't have
this establishment
that was presiding over,
I think this cultural
and economic decay,
then I wouldn't have to,
but that's not where
we are and I have to,
and I think we need some
new thinking in government.
So it's also the most important
thing I could be doing.
I didn't think this was
the case in like 2012
when I was taking
those notes, I thought,
you know, I saw Mitt
Romney lose to Barack Obama
and it's like, how could
this possibly happen?
I thought the first
Obama term was so bad
that of course like a successful
businessman, governor,
Mitt Romney, he
even looks the part,
(chuckles)
of course he's gonna win.
- He definitely
looks the part yeah.
- And then it was just a,
I think he was too nice
and just sort of
failed to understand
this was a fight for the future
of the country, and he lost.
And to me, I was always been
political, but it's sorta like,
well, if the, if the
right, if conservatives,
if Republicans just aren't
gonna be serious about winning,
maybe it's just the
controlled opposition
and we're just gonna have a
managed decline politically
and that's why I wanted
to go into business.
It's like I could
actually do something.
You could start in and
invest in startups.
And if we can get technology
to work sort of faster
than government can
retard progress,
then maybe we can
have a good future.
So, I basically thought
it was all over,
honestly until 2016 and
Trump comes on the scene
and sort of busts
up the establishment
and whatever your view of
that is like he did it.
I think it's great.
- Mm-hmm.
- I felt the administration
was very successful,
but he showed me that new
things are possible in politics.
And I think we need much
more of a startup mentality
because we have too
much stagnation,
too much bureaucracy, we're
really drowning in it.
- Yeah.
So it's just time for.
- I've never thought
about it this way,
but would you
consider Trump in 2016
as sort of a zero to one moment.
- Totally.
- In politics?
- Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
He came, I thought it was,
it was sort of refreshing,
it was really honest.
I mean, I think this
is why he was elected.
He was like the one
person telling the truth,
which is this left establishment
and the right establishment.
It doesn't work like people,
it was the emperor
has no clothes moment.
- Yeah.
- Where he's just like,
you, you, you, you're
getting screwed,
you're getting ripped off.
China's eating her
lunch, you know?
And he'd been remarkably
consistent about that
decade over decade.
And I think people that
resonated with them,
like the election that we
deserved in 2016 was Trump
versus Bernie Sanders.
- Mm-hm.
- Which of course the
DNC wouldn't let happen
and they rigged it.
- Right.
- So that
Bernie couldn't win.
But, and I disagree with
Bernie Sanders on everything,
I think he's just wrong.
Like that left wing sort
of communist politics,
like that doesn't work.
But Bernie was at least
more honest than Hillary
because he came on the scene
and said like, this is rigged.
This establishment
is failing people.
And that's what Trump's
message was too,
they just had very different
policy prescriptions.
And I think Trump's
were much better.
- Do you kind of admire
the sort of evilness
of the DNC in a way,
like that they've rigged
it against Bernie and.
- Admire is too strong.
- Well, admire,
the way I always say.
- You gotta respect it
in a sort of.
- Yeah.
Well, admire like the
way the doctor admired
the alien in the
first alien movie,
you know, it was so merciless.
- Right.
- That he was
killing everything.
- Yeah.
- And it had no remorse.
- Yeah, look, the left
is serious about power
and they know how
to play the game.
And again, there's something
horrible about that,
but they played to win.
And so often Republicans
don't play to win.
We play to be Mr. Nice guy
and then try to get some
sinecure at some think tank,
you know, when we lose.
And I think people
are just sick of that,
'cause our backs
against the wall,
there's no more room
to play defense.
What do you do about
the nice guy part?
- Cause I heard you speak a
couple of weeks ago here in LA
and my general takeaway,
I know you a little bit
through Twitter mostly,
but my takeaway was,
oh, he's a nice guy.
Like, do you think that
can actually work in this,
like that we need these
sort of corrupt mean people
willing to do horrible
shit to become politicians?
- Well, I think you
got to play to win
and I'm definitely
playing to win.
So I think I present
like a reasonable person,
I think I am a nice
person or whatever,
but I care more about doing the
right thing than being nice.
And so I'm sure at some
point in the campaign,
like I wanna run a
positive campaign,
I think that's how
I break through
by showing people in
Arizona how I'm different,
but I'm sure the
things come out,
I can be sharp elbowed and
I think you have to be,
I have super thick skin.
I don't think it's about
being mean for the sake of it,
but I do think we
have to understand,
like right now we're playing
for the future of the country.
And I think if the left wins,
we won't have a good country.
We won't even have a country
in 30 years necessarily.
So I think the stakes
are really high
and I'm willing to do
what it takes to win
and shore it up so that we
can have a successful future.
I don't think that means
be brash and be rude,
but I do think it means
Republicans have to get serious
about like acquiring
and using power
to sort of build a
society that works.
- Brash and rude comes
when you run for president.
- There you go.
- It's one thing at a time.
- It's just sending out.
If you had to really
just sort of sum up
your political positions,
it strikes me as
some sort of blend
between like a
traditional conservative
with libertarian leaning,
something like that.
Is that kind of fair to say?
- Yeah, I've been there
to libertarianism.
It's like, I grew
up with Ayn Rand
and Milton Friedman.
- Yeah.
- On the bookshelf
in college, I got super
into the Austrian school,
you know, von Mises and
total free market economics.
And I think it's very
important to understand,
I think it's good to be
coming from that place.
I also think we need to update.
So it's like, I'm a
very pro market guy,
very pro pro-business guy,
but like there is no free
trade with China, you know?
And so if you have
these free trade people
negotiating trade
agreements with China,
there's a sense in
which you just lose
because China doesn't
have free trade.
Like they're always the way
that society works, right?
CCPs just subsidizing
domestic industries,
they can dump steel, it's just
not a level playing field.
And so we, you
know, for decades,
we have free traders at
the negotiating table,
and the worst they
are at negotiating,
the better they
think they've done.
- Right.
- It's free trade,
we can't possibly put a tariff
on China and it's like, no,
we took all this productive
industrial capacity
and we shipped it to
Southeast Asia to save a buck.
And in theory, that's
economically efficient
and in practice it hollows out
your sort of middle
American economy,
I think to the great
detriment of most Americans.
And so I think I'm generally
like a pro market guy,
laissez-faire as much
as possible internally,
but like, you
gotta pay attention
to your trade
relationship with China.
And I think for the longest time
Republicans and
Democrats botched it
and president Trump came on,
and again, emperor has no
clothes moment, he's just like,
what are you guys doing?
(chuckles)
This is stupid.
They're eating your lunch.
- Yeah.
- And that was true.
So.
- And yet
he's not president anymore.
- He's not president anymore,
which is a big shame,
but like his policies
were working,
wages in this country
stagnated from 1970
or at least the early 70s
all the way until 2016,
and they finally
started going up,
median wages finally started
going up under president Trump
and he basically gets
no credit for that.
And now all those
gains are reversed
because Biden and Harris are
just reversing the policies.
So I think there's room
to be like a super
pro market Republican,
but also understand that markets
are supposed to be tools
for human flourishing,
like the goal is a successful,
productive society,
right, the goal is not some
abstract economic ideal.
- Is that what conservatives
have sort of forgotten
how to argue for,
I get the.
- Yeah.
- Libertarian stuff for sure,
but they've sort
of traded in that,
oh, there's a greater good here.
- Yeah.
- That we should
all be trying to attain.
- What's it all for.
- And it's that
sort of disappear again.
- That's right, and
it's why I think,
on the right, you have
big business interests
that are super pro
open borders, right?
Because they just care
about cheap labor.
- Right.
- And there's a way
you can rationalize
that with GDP
or sort of economic
efficiency arguments,
but they don't look at the
consequences to society,
you know, or in my
announcement video,
I had a controversial line,
it was amazing that it
was even controversial,
I would've thought
it was common sense,
but I said, you
ought to be able to
raise a family in America
on one single income.
- Doesn't mean you hate
women or something?
- That's what the
Democrats said.
(chuckles)
They attacked me
for being sexist, and it's like,
I didn't say anything
sexist at all.
You used to be able
to raise a family
on one income in this country.
Something happened and
globalization happened,
maybe it's a complicated
story to tell,
but you can't do it anymore
and I think that's a problem.
And maybe a husband and wife,
maybe the wife
wants to go to work
and the husband wants to stay
at home and raise the kids.
I generally think it's good
if someone stays at home
and raises the kids,
or maybe you wanna have.
- Hmm.
- Two people work and that's
fine, that should be a choice,
you should be able to afford
to raise a family, you know?
So I didn't say you couldn't
choose, I just said,
wouldn't it be nice if
we were more prosperous?
But that's not the way so
many even people on the right
have come to think,
it's more like,
well, think about all the GDP,
if we send the husband to work
and you send the wife to work
or your husband and husband,
whatever, you send to workers,
and then you've got
to get the nanny
and now you've got three incomes
and look at all this GDP that
we're creating, you know?
Well, it's like, what if that's
not as good for the kids?
Wouldn't it be nice
to have the choice?
But apparently not,
(chuckles)
apparently not.
- Well, what do we
call this new thing?
Like, is this what populism,
like the new populism
of the right is,
like what is it sort of,
because I think
when you say gender,
not you specifically,
but when people say,
even if now I say,
I don't mind if people
call me a conservative,
now I would say I'm sort of
like a future conservative
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- But when you say conservative
to like a 20 year old,
they freak out like,
like, oh, that
doesn't sound right.
- There's a branding problem.
- Yeah.
What do you do about that?
- I don't think populist is
necessarily the right label.
Like I don't mind if
people call me that,
I don't call myself that.
I do think what I'm espousing
are conservative messages.
I consider myself conservative,
but obviously you can't
keep everything the same,
society moves on.
And so it's about sort of this,
you gotta be a little
bit wise about it.
Like what's worked in the past?
What's good about what we've
inherited from our ancestors?
I think there's a
whole lot, right,
the left wants to throw
everything out about the past,
because it's not
perfect right now,
so everything in the past
must be irredeemable and evil,
right, and that's a mistake.
We got to take so much
of what we've inherited
and just think about how to
conserve it in the future
while also adapting
to new things.
So I think it's conservative,
but it's not like ostrich
barrier head in the sand
and just repeat whatever Ronald
Reagan was saying, right.
And I think conservatives
need to update.
So whether you want,
I think it's just a new
Republican party
that we're building,
you know, Paul
Ryanism doesn't work.
- Right.
- I think Reagan did
what he had to do in the 80s
and people have basically
just been trying to
copy him ever since.
But and this is just
the point, Zero to One,
if you just look at Facebook,
you look at Ronald Reagan,
you look at what
worked in the past
and if you just mindlessly
copy it decade over decade,
you'll get to a point
where that thing doesn't
even work anymore,
except you haven't invested
the time or the energy
and thinking about like what
you should be saying now.
- We're gonna talk a little
more about big tech in a bit,
but like, are you worried that
even if all the ideas
are right and decent
and pretty much most people
can get on board that,
between the media and big
tech and everything else
that they just won't let
those ideas be heard in a way
that the average person
could get across.
I mean, you know,
I was out there
on the campaign trail with
Larry Elder and it was like,
this guy was saying a lot
of what you just said there.
- Right.
- And he's a
very decent man and the
pedigree that he has
and everything else and the
media treated him horribly.
- Right.
- I mean the black face
of white supremacy.
- Black face of white supremacy.
- Yeah.
- I do worry about that,
although I think
California has just gone
to a first approximation.
- Yeah, and thanks
for coming by.
- Thanks.
It's good to visit California.
- Yeah.
- Also good to get back home.
(chuckles)
- Yeah.
- Arizona's not there yet
and I think the
country's not there yet.
I think if Arizona goes
the way of California,
if the country goes the way
of California, it's all over.
It's just a one party
state, it's dysfunctional.
Yeah, you can't
get a fair hearing,
but these ideas are popular,
it's basically like you
should be pro business
and pro market,
but make sure that
that's actually working
for the working class
and middle class.
Like most people in
America agree with me that
in this country,
you should be able to raise a
family on one single income.
Like the criticism of that
statement is that it's been all
because I haven't said
how I'm gonna do that,
it's more just like Blake,
you're just saying it's good
to be prosperous or something,
but people shouldn't be
picking fights with it
because it's sexist
or because it's impossible.
- Right.
- Like that's just giving up.
And so, another thing
I'm talking about
on the campaign trail,
is just education.
And there's a partisan
way to talk about this
where I think the
left-wing ideology,
1619 project and
critical race theory,
all that stuff is horrible,
but even if you wipe
that stuff away,
if we got rid of it
tomorrow, that'd be great
and it would also not
fix our schools, right?
Because our schools have
been failing for decades.
It's like you graduate kids
that can't even read or write
because we just
lower the standards
and we failed to
teach the basics.
And so I think when you
point this stuff out,
it's not even that ideological,
it's just so many things
about our society don't work.
And we just need new leadership
that is gonna privilege
competence and execution
over anything else.
- How do you think
you also show people
that politics is in everything.
- Mm-hmm.
- That politics is in God
and the meaning of life
and everything else,
because that's what it's
become to so many people?
- Right.
- So to say,
hey, I'm not gonna solve
all of your problems,
we're gonna try to make things
better, we're gonna try to,
as you said, take the good
stuff, bring in some new stuff,
but like we can't solve
every single thing.
- And part of it is
getting out there
with that exact message
and reminding people that,
because, thinking
about like my cohort,
I'm a millennial and thinking
about generation Z below me,
these kids are so attracted
to the left wing totalitarian
message, the AOC stuff, right?
The progressive ideology and
that's a totalizing ideology,
it does purport to
solve all your problems.
It's just like, just
believe in the party line
and give the state
unlimited power
and we'll take
care of everybody,
cradle to grave in a
literal sense, right.
But then also the wokeism,
the progressivism,
it is a substitute religion.
You know, I've come to believe
it's basically a militant
form of Christianity,
sort of devoid of all the
redemption and the benefit.
And so it is a whole
totalizing philosophy,
but I think that's really scary.
And I think if you
remind people like,
hey, this is where that goes
when you follow that path,
you know, we have so
many historical examples
and you remind people
like that's not the
job of government,
like government's job
is to create conditions
so that people can flourish
and protect people's rights
so that people can figure out
the meaning of
life on their own.
You know, I do think we need
a sort of re Christianization.
I do think a religious
revival in America
would be very good, it's not
my job to make that happen.
But what you're seeing with
the woke takeover of everything
is something very
much like that,
I just think it's so crazy.
60 or 70% of people in this
country won't go for it.
If we have messengers who can
say like, this is horrible.
- Do you see this thing,
everything that you
described there,
do you see that as sort of the,
what I would say
is at this point,
the obvious end of sort of
purely secular liberalism
that at the end of just,
I believe only in
what's here and now,
you're going to get all of this
crazy hysteria
around government.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause people
need to believe
one way or another.
- People definitely
need to believe.
- They can say
they don't believe,
but they believe.
- Yep, no,
we have a religious impulse
and when the left doesn't
think they believe in God
or Christianity,
this is what we get.
And I think that's really
worked, I think it's bad,
I think it is hurting
a lot of people
and I think it'll
hurt a lot more.
It's a militant sort
of secular religion,
they think they're atheists,
but actually it's just,
it's really devastating.
- It's just shifted.
- You mentioned potentially
a husband and husband.
It seems to me that
the Republicans
have pretty much all
moved on gay marriage,
do you see any issue there
when you're talking about
some of the religious stuff
or even maybe some of the base
that still isn't quite there?
- Yeah.
I don't see it.
- I mean,
I'm in super Republican activist
rooms every day in Arizona
and I just don't
hear that at all.
You know, my hometown
Congressman in Tucson,
I was growing up, Jim Colby,
He was the first openly
gay member of Congress,
if not, he was an early one.
But when he spoke at
the 2000 convention
in favor of George W.
Bush, his nomination,
I remember the Texas delegation
actually turned their
back on Jim Colby
when he was speaking, right,
that's sort of where
the country was
or that's where
Texas was in 2000.
And then in 2016, right,
fast forward, 16 years later,
I'm there in Cleveland, at
the RNC convention with Peter.
- Mm-hmm.
- And Peter gave the speech
and he had this line where
he said, I'm proud to be gay.
- Yeah.
- I'm proud to be Republican,
but most of all,
right, applause line,
I'm proud to be an American.
And.
- The crowd went nuts.
- The crowd went nuts,
you know?
And the Trump kids were sitting
in a sort of private
VIP box there
and they all stood
up and applauded,
right, it was just to
me, I was a bookend.
- I was watching that on TV
and it was before I
had ever met Peter
and I was still a
lefty at the time
and I remember thinking,
whoa, something just happened.
- Right.
- Just now,
like when they all exploded,
but of course the next day,
the media doesn't.
- Right.
- They don't give you anything
on that, right?
- Right?
- Yeah.
- Occasionally.
- If anything, he's
somehow a sell out
for doing it or
something like that.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- Right.
Yeah, no, I think people
have moved beyond this.
I think there's a sort of
personal libertarian streak
at least in Arizona, right,
Republicans don't care.
They don't care what you do,
they don't care
what your family,
but they don't want to feel,
they don't wanna feel
like they're a bigot
or something because
they're not on board with.
Create a quick story hour.
- Exactly.
- How about that.
- Exactly, right.
And so some people say like,
gosh, where does it stop?
Right.
Every fortune 500 company
seems to have these
political messages,
you know, pro LGBT messages.
And if you believe
what most Americans believed
three years ago, you're racist
and you're bigot and
you're retrograde.
People don't want that, they
don't wanna be bludgeoned
over the head with some agenda.
But I think most people are
like pretty living that live.
And I think that's a positive
development for the country.
So I hear basically
none of this.
- Yeah, I'm with you.
I just felt it was worth asking
'cause I do see
some little tension
on some of the stuff
going on with the right,
there's this sort of
like Catholic revival
in the midst of this.
- Sure.
- Where they're sort of
against it, and it's like,
how do you blend that
with the libertarian part?
- Sure.
- So.
- But that's a broad problem
that has to deal with stuff.
- Just like the real
problem with marriage,
gay or straight is that
people just get divorced.
- Right.
- People don't get married,
you wait longer and longer
and people aren't
forming families,
and then when they do,
they fall apart, you know?
'Cause I think every
force in society
basically conspires against
young people coupling
and that's really bad,
but I don't think that's
a gay, straight issue,
I think everybody's,
divorce rates are too
high for everyone.
- Yeah, you mentioned
you're a millennial.
How old are you?
- 35.
- 35, so I'm 45.
I'm gen X.
- Gen X,
I'm sorry about that.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
Well then you already
answered the question.
Do you feel like,
'cause I feel this way
that gen X basically
got completely
passed over somehow.
- Totally.
- The boomers are
still hanging on.
- They will never let
go of their power, yeah.
- They just won't let go,
and they, I mean Biden,
and Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer and even Trump.
I mean, we've got
all of these people
in their late 70s into 80s
still running the show.
It should be the 45
year olds right now
in the prime of things
and yet maybe we're just
gonna be skipped over
and it'll be you
young bucks at 35.
- You definitely get screwed.
- Yeah.
(chuckles)
- I agree Pelosi and Schumer
should relinquish their
power immediately.
I like Trump,
I hope he runs again.
- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
- But he's the one
I would wanna see who's
in that generation run.
- Right.
I don't think you're bad because
of your age obviously, but.
- We need a changing
of the guard.
- Yeah.
- I mean, we really just do,
I think the median age
of the US Senate is 63,
which is pretty crazy 'cause
it's the median, right?
So there's a lot of
senators that are 70, 80.
Dianne Feinstein is like a 127
or something.
- Hey, you know?
And it's actually,
I just kind of feel bad for her,
like it's not clear
she knows where she is.
- Yeah.
- And the Biden thing,
you know?
I mean, people make fun of it
and okay, fine, fair enough,
it's rough and
tumble in politics,
but it's actually really sad.
I think it's really sad.
I think it crazy.
- Yeah, yeah.
that we have a president
that clearly doesn't
have a grip on things,
like he's just not there.
That's not even an
ideological criticism,
he's just not fully
able to do the job.
- Do you think if it was Trump,
they may be, would be
talking about that.
Would that be such a
bold, crazy statement?
- I wonder if the
media would have
something to say about that.
- He once drank with a cup,
remember the glass.
- Oh my gosh, yeah.
- With two hands that was.
- It's so wild.
neurological disorder.
- It's just gaslighting.
- Yeah.
They think people are stupid,
they think we can't actually see
that president Biden cannot
string a sentence together.
And this is really crazy.
One thing that's interesting
that I have not heard
on the campaign trail,
oh, Blake, you're too
young to be a US Senator.
- Hmm.
- And I was sort of
bracing myself for
that line of criticism.
You know, 'cause I do have
20 years or 30 years even
on some of my competitors,
but people do not feel this way.
Actually two thirds
of the Republican
primary electorate in
Arizona is over 55.
So it's not particularly
young electorate,
but those people love me.
' Cause like how radical is it
to actually see a
young conservative
who's been paying attention,
who knows history,
who knows about the
good things in the past,
who knows how important it
is to carry this forward,
but also is young and has
the energy and you can admit,
you know, I got a lot
of skin in the game.
Hopefully I have a long runway
left and I have young kids
and I really care about the
country they're growing up in.
And I think so many of the
baby boomer politicians,
my competition in the
primary, they're fine,
you know, whatever,
but there's a business
guy and a military guy
and a politician and it's
just, you have the career
and then you finish the career
and it's like, well,
retirement sucks, it's boring.
And you don't wanna
think about mortality.
And so you're just
looking for that capstone.
And so you have all
the cliche stuff,
like I'm just ready to go back
and serve my community.
- Mm-hmm.
- You know and it's like,
no man, I'm fighting for
the future of this country.
- So how much of everything
sort of that feels wrong with
the country right now is that,
it's that tension between
things that are collapsing
that aren't working anymore.
Even media like watching CNN
that now we can
expose their lies
every two seconds online.
- Right.
- Which we couldn't
10 years ago.
And then their lies
seem to get more brazen,
that it's attention between
like the mainstream media
and the internet culture,
tension between young and old,
like we're just at this weird
turning point right now.
- Right.
I think it's just stagnation,
and ultimately it doesn't work
and the people who have
been in charge of it
and presided over it,
won't admit that, you know.
- Does that give you hope
that as right now it feels
where it's getting
out of control
that it may be is
at its dead end
in some way maybe.
- It does,
it does, it's weird.
'Cause it's simultaneously
a very pessimistic message,
like I'm up on the
campaign trail every night
telling people like
it's really bad.
Like my competition.
- Yeah.
- Like our best days are
right around the corner.
And it's like, I think
that sounds fake to people.
I hope our best days are in
the future and I am excited
and optimistic and
that's why I'm running
because I think we can arrest
the decline and reverse it
and have a good
country going forward,
but it's really bleak.
I think it's really bleak,
I think things have not
been working for so long.
I think fiscal crises loom,
we're just printing tons
of money, seeing inflation.
It's just not gonna work
this whole monetary
policy that we have,
the system itself,
I don't know whether it
has two years or 20 years,
but I don't think
it has 50 years.
- Wait, wait,
are you trying to tell
me that 3.5 trillion
doesn't equal zero.
- Wow.
- Because
I have a calculator back.
- And what is that?
- I was told.
- It's like in the past
Democrats have wanted
to spend a lot of money
would have been honest
enough to say like,
this is expensive, it's an
investment in ourselves, right,
I mean, this goes back
to the founding father,
Alexander Hamilton was like,
public debt, we owe
it to ourselves,
like sometimes you gotta
invest in improvements.
And there's a fair
debate to have
if you acknowledge the sort
of stakes at the debate,
like if you have to spend 3.5
trillion, make the argument.
But again, they think
people are stupid
and they think they can come
and say two plus two is four,
3.5 trillion equals
zero, it's free.
- Yeah.
- My build back better agenda
is free.
It costs nothing, it's paid for.
And it's like, what
the hell is that?
If you buy a $2 million house,
cause you have $2 million,
like your house isn't free,
(laughing)
it cost $2 million, you know.
- This was the burrito example
I used with this guy the other
day, if you're at Chipotle
and you order a burrito and
they're like, it's 10 bucks.
And then you just punch
the guy behind you
and take his 10 bucks,
it still costs 10 bucks.
- Yeah.
No, it's free, it's free.
So it's crazy, I don't know,
and I guess this
stuff works over time.
I mean, they know
what they're doing.
This is a calculated sort
of linguistic manipulation.
- But do you think
it's because they think
they can get away with it,
like they think the media well,
because they do the media
then just repeats it
as if it's true.
- They do.
- Yeah.
- But I think the
media stranglehold
is just weaker than
it's ever been.
- Yeah.
- Right.
And I give president Trump
huge credit for this.
I think the mainstream media
was garbage frankly before 2016.
- Yeah.
- Peddling
the same sort of fake
bi-partisan Senator
left narrative.
But I think Trump came along
and totally just picked
a fight with them
and it was crazy and
chaotic and all that,
but he de-legitimized
the mainstream media.
And so we live in this sort
of information environment
that's kind of wild,
it's hard to know who's
telling the truth,
it's hard to know who to trust
and then even if
someone is trustworthy,
they might be wrong
about some deeds.
So people have to do the work
and read a lot of things,
like COVID,
it's like, how do you actually
know what's happening?
Right, is it the hugest
problem in the world?
I suspect not anymore.
Is it sort of serious
and we should pay
attention to these things
or is it completely fake?
And you know, it's
hard to actually know.
- Yeah.
- Like literally
how many people
are dying of COVID?
And at this point, the
problem is experts,
the expert class has totally
de-legitimized itself.
And so if you can't
listen to experts,
who can you listen to, right.
And so I think people
don't know what to believe.
There's a version of this
about like election
integrity in Arizona.
- Mm-hmm.
- Right,
we just had this audit come
out and it's fascinating for me
because I'm campaigning,
I'm in these Republican
activist rooms
and before the audit
came out at least
I'd be talking to people
who were just sure
that dominion voting
systems switch,
you know, whatever it is,
300,000 votes for Trump.
- Mm-hmm.
- Switch them to Biden
and it was simply
rigged or something.
And that's not my view.
I do think the election was
unfair and stolen in some sense,
I think you could point to like
tremendous amounts
of irregularities,
and I think on the margin,
certainly Democrats
cheat and steal
and in Arizona, there's a
ballot harvesting problem,
it's technically illegal,
but it goes on policed,
but I never really thought,
and I think the
audit shows this,
that it wasn't as simple
as a cartoonish rigging
of 300,000 votes.
- Hmm.
- But I'm just so sympathetic
to people who do think that
because they know the media
would be happy to lie to them,
almost every
journalist would lie
to hurt president Trump in some
sense, election experts say,
studies show that people
know that this narrative
is so massaged and so
fake, and so I think
when people can't trust
the institutions anymore,
when they can't trust the
experts, they will latch on
to whatever sort of
emotionally feels right.
- You would agree,
a great Twitter thread on this,
because you were talking about
this and then you referenced,
I think it was that Atlantic,
was it Atlantic, the article
where they said it was,
they were fortifying
the election.
- Time Magazine.
- So that,
they basically say a cabal
of people figured out
how to fortify the election.
- Yeah.
- And it's like, then the
average person reads that
and even if you don't have
the numbers right in
front of you to go,
oh, they cheated this
way specifically,
it's kind of like if you
thought that Hitler was
gonna be reelected,
you might cheat, right?
Like you might.
- They spent years
saying that president Trump
was evil incarnate, right.
In 2019 as late as 2019,
Nancy Pelosi said he was
a illegitimate president,
only elected because Russia
put them, this crazy shit,
like, it was really crazy.
- Yeah.
Yeah, Hillary still
got the tweet up,
he's a legitimate president.
- Really crazy stuff.
And then we actually have
tons of irregularities,
you actually do have this
sort of, I think center left,
left wing media, NGO,
corporate fusion of power that
gets together and says like,
how do we get Trump out?
We know this happened,
we know they had
motive and opportunity,
like we know that they
were trying everything
and then they brag about it.
- Yeah.
- In Time Magazine,
we just had to make
sure that democracy
achieved the right result.
I mean, it's really sinister,
it's really Orwellian.
- Yeah.
- And so when you see all this,
that's why I'm just
so sympathetic to
people who believe,
even the wildest things
about the election.
- No.
- It wasn't fair,
I think Trump wins
in a fair fight,
it's like Pfizer knew
that they had received,
or were about to
receive emergency
approval for the vaccine
before the election.
But then we didn't find out
about it until
after the election
and their official
narrative on this is
what we didn't want to
influence the election.
And it's like,
Trump's warp speed
was a huge development in 2020,
like we created the
vaccine so quickly
and maybe a lot of
people might want him
to have known about that
before casting their vote.
And Pfizer just decided
not to release that info.
So in what sense is that fair?
- How do you decide how much
you can talk about this stuff?
Like whether your base really
wants you to talk about it
'cause obviously Arizona
just went through the audit
versus mainstream, like
when the audit came out,
I actually didn't even
send a tweet about it
'cause I was like,
it's hard to understand what
happened here, I was just like,
it's a headache.
- Yup.
- Because I'm gonna get
an endless amount of hate
and maybe be demonetized
or my video will be deleted.
- Right.
- Or whatever.
So how do you balance
between sort of maybe
what some of the base wants,
how you feel about things
and then what will be accepted?
I mean, it all kind of sucks,
but you're a politician now.
- Yeah, but the
best way to do it,
I think is to not
over calculate.
Some people criticize me,
I had a big Twitter
thread before the audit,
and I said like, remember
before the Friday
where the audit
results came out,
I said, regardless
of what happens,
like we're gonna learn
something tomorrow,
but regardless, let's remember,
the election was sort of
unfair and deeply troubled,
deeply problematic in
all these different ways.
And I cataloged them 'cause I
wanted that out in the record.
Then the audit comes up Friday
and I didn't tweet
about it until Saturday
because I actually wanted to
read the report.
- Mm-hmm.
- And see what happens.
- Crazy, crazy, right.
- Right, instead of just
immediately latch on
because there's a lot there
and people criticize me
for that, but it's like,
I wasn't gonna have
the consultant improve
preplanned tweet,
just ready to go and beat
up on political enemies,
I wanted to see what it said.
And so I read it.
So the best way I know
how to campaign, right,
and it's my first time
but I think people are
ready for like authenticity.
Like I never say anything
that I don't think is true.
I will go into these
Republican activist rooms
and they may not
like what I'm saying,
but they will see that,
like I'm telling them
the truth as I see it
and that's the best I can do.
And it's tough because
sometimes these
people want you to
parrot back exactly
what they say.
- Right.
- And if you don't,
then you're a rhino or
something like that.
But then I just
say like, hey man,
I'm obviously like with you.
- Right.
- I'm a
very conservative person, sort
of libertarian individualist.
- Mm-hmm.
- I'm different
than conservatives
you've seen before,
but I'm obviously with you,
I see it from a
different perspective.
- I know the feeling, man.
I know the feeling.
- But I think people like that.
- Yeah.
- Whereas you can't,
I don't think you can
survive as a politician
if you're just in this room
saying what they wanna hear
and then you go to
a different room,
you say what they wanna hear.
Obviously you talk
to different groups,
somewhat differently
based on their interests.
But all I can do is tell
the truth as I see it
and just go and share
that message with people.
- Right.
And that goes to the
tension of the internet
now exposing a lot of stuff,
in the old days,
you could do that.
- Right.
- You could go to one room
and say one day,
and you can prove.
- It's completely fake
and I think we trained
a whole generation
of fake politicians on that
and the internet I think
is kind of a crazy place,
but it's healthy
in this respect.
I think it exposes who's
for real and who's not.
And I think, it's like,
remember the Elizabeth Warren
drink a beer in the kitchen.
- I'm gonna get me a beer.
- And then she, her husband
is like, come over here.
And then Trump was
savage on that.
(chuckles)
He was so good, right.
He's like what, the husband's
supposed to be there,
what's happening, right.
(laughing)
He's just like,
and you know, there were
like 50 people in that room.
- Yeah.
- Consultants
and media people,
and it was just fake.
- I'm gonna get me a beer.
- I'm gonna get,
gosh, and it's like.
- I kept saying it
throughout the campaign,
how can this billionaire
hair plugged orange man
be more authentic than
all of these people.
- He's so authentic.
- And he is, he absolutely is.
So all right,
we're shifting a little
bit to the internet stuff,
so I wanna talk about
the big tech thing.
You've been very big.
- Yeah.
- On the big tech thing
and what do we do?
This is the perfect
blend of like,
okay, libertarian principles,
free market, all of that
but society seems to be.
- Yeah.
- Crumbling under algorithms.
- Yep.
- What do we do?
- We got to reign in big tech.
We just have to,
I think five years ago,
people weren't ready for this,
the big tech companies
actually were less abusive.
They'd grown a lot, like
things have changed.
And this is what I mean, you
need people in leadership,
people in office who were
tracking these changes
and who can intervene.
I think I'm a pro-market guy.
Peter invested in
Facebook, that's fantastic.
We want companies
that we invest in
to become huge and successful,
but at a certain point when
companies become more powerful
than most governments,
when a handful of
corporations come to dominate
and control the flow of
information in society,
I think we can afford to
treat them differently
than you might treat a
bakery or a hair salon.
And so I really just worry about
Google being able to
swing an election.
At least when Facebook
rips the Hunter Biden
story off the internet
two or three weeks
before the election.
- Hmm.
- Which is complete crap
and they shouldn't
be allowed to do it,
but when they did
that, people noticed
and you have the Streisand
effect sort of thing
where it's this discussion.
- Right.
- We can talk about it,
and at least the
censorship was transparent,
but with Google, they can
change their search algorithms
to if they're subtle enough,
I think you could change
it a meaningful amount.
- Mm-hmm.
- Suppress this information
about Trump and boost this
information about Biden
and all of a sudden,
do you really live in
a free country anymore?
And so I think we have
to pay attention to this,
conservatives focus
a lot on censorship.
And I think we should
because conservatives
really are sensitive,
they ripped president Trump
off Facebook and Twitter
while he was president.
- Yeah.
- And meanwhile,
Taliban commanders
have blue check marks.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so this is crazy
and censorship is
a huge problem.
And I think, you can
repeal section 230
and you can treat the
platforms as common carriers,
which I think we should do.
But I think the problems with
big tech are a lot deeper too.
I worry a lot about like
targeted advertising.
- Mm-hmm.
- And you just saw
the study that
came out last week
that showed how bad
Instagram is for teenagers.
- Yeah.
- Especially teenage women,
like their mental health.
- And it's like,
surprise, surprise, everyone's
pretending they're shocked.
Oh my God,
I can't believe that.
- We knew this, right.
- Yeah.
- You knew this.
- And it's just
the endless feed
and then you hoover up
all this data about people
and use it in pretty
predatory ways,
sort of subterranean, you're
hacking their psychology.
Like these companies employ
psychologists on staff.
- Mm-hmm.
- As well as
software designers to get
people hooked on the products,
to get evermore data, to serve
them evermore targeted ads.
And think we shouldn't be doing
that at least for teenagers,
like we shouldn't be allowing
Facebook to advertise to kids.
And right now.
- In some ways
it's too late though.
Like I know we can do things
and let's say you
get into the Senate
and we have the hearings and
everyone's seen the hearings
and even guys that I
like at the hearings,
like Ted Cruz.
- Those hearings are brutal.
- But they're brutal
no matter what,
because even when
there's a nice moment
when Rand Paul really
gets jacket Twitter
or Ted Cruz does some, really
gets somebody caught in a lie,
nothing ever changes.
So is it possible that
we've now been manipulated?
This is sort of my like
matrix version of this,
we've been manipulated in so
many ways now for enough years
that no matter what you could
do as part of the government,
it would be like, yeah,
you know, drop in a barrel.
- I agree that's a risk,
but I think that's,
to just conclude that
is to give up.
- Yeah.
- And so I don't,
I think there's at least
still a really good chance.
You can do a lot,
maybe not to start,
one Senator can't really
unilaterally pass a bill, right,
but I think I'm gonna get in
there and make so much noise
and actually run effective
hearings, and like,
I think I really do know what
to do with these companies
like Josh Holly's.
- Yeah.
- Holly's shown a lot
of leadership on this
and if you get a core group of
five or six people like that,
you get the ball rolling,
it may take some time,
but I think we actually can
make meaningful progress here
because I think also big tech
is just gonna get bigger
and bigger, right.
These structural monopolies,
they just become
ever more profitable,
like, unless we reign them in,
they're just gonna take
over more and more ground,
especially now that like they're
not even private companies,
right,
like Facebook is working
with the Biden administration
to decide what is
COVID misinformation.
- Yep.
- Jen Psaki says, Facebook
pull this off and Facebook,
like a good boy pulls it off.
- Yeah.
- And that's really crazy.
- We flag things
for Facebook.
- Yeah.
- Of course
they're a private company
and they can make
their own decisions,
of course, we have a giant FTC,
(laughing)
under Elena Kagan.
- Right.
- That we're gonna use
as a giant threat
to make you comply.
I think this stuff
is really dangerous.
I don't think we can afford
to give up, you know.
Possibly these companies
are too big and powerful,
possibly they'll just
do everything they can
to make sure that people
like me don't get elected,
but it's a risk we have to take.
- Yeah.
- Because otherwise
we're throwing in the towel.
- When I heard you speak
a couple of weeks ago,
somebody asked you something
about this and basically you,
that was your answer, and
then you said at the end,
like you were like, well, what
are they gonna do, kill me?
And everyone kind of
got quiet for a second,
but it's like, who knows.
- I hope not.
- Yeah, but it's like, who knows
what these people could do,
what they could do.
I'm not saying they're
coming to kill you,
but like just the way
they can manipulate
and make everybody
hate everybody.
And again, after what I saw
what they did to Larry Elder
and when I would Google his name
after I'd be at rallies
where there was so much love,
so much support.
- Yep.
- And every single article
in Google, it was like,
I think 12 out of the
15 on the first page,
hit piece, hit piece, hit piece.
- Right.
- And it's like, it's like
a digital assassination.
- Right.
Yeah, no, I mean, I think
it'll get really ugly.
I do.
But I think, and I think
social media is really flawed
like maybe the world
isn't instantly,
shouldn't be instantly
connected, you know?
So you can outrage
mobs in London
because some something
happened in the US,
like that's actually a
really weird phenomenon,
this hyper-connectivity.
- Hmm.
- I don't think
that's going away,
I don't think we can,
or necessarily even
should make that go away.
But I do think like,
nope, super powerful
multinational corporations
shouldn't have the
power and the ability
to swing an election,
and I don't think,
past a certain point,
past a certain market cap,
or once you have a 100
million users on your platform
or whatever, I think
you're a common carrier.
And the phone company can't
discriminate against us.
- Hmm.
- Because we have
political views
and so Facebook shouldn't
be able to do it either.
To me, that's like the bare
minimum that we need to do.
- You mean Alex Jones should
be entitled to a phone.
- Oh my gosh.
(chuckles)
Yeah, imagine,
and it was just
getting worse, right?
Banking,
I know like Republican
political operatives in Arizona,
Wells Fargo has just shut out.
- Yeah.
- They at least had the grace
to allow these people
to withdraw their money
before disclosing the accounts.
But like pretty soon, like
we are moving this way,
social credit systems, right?
Like we thought that
helping China industrialize
would make them more like us,
we thought it would turn them
into a liberal democracy,
no, actually,
our society is
becoming remarkably a
lot more like China.
- Yeah.
- That's sort of oligarchy
controlled by a few people.
Obviously our version
looks different,
but I think they're
using big tech,
I think they're using
the universities,
they're using corporations,
NGOs, Ford foundation,
all this stuff, it's
really part of this web
that just kind of swims left.
- Do you wanna
seize their money?
I think J.D. Vance that said.
- J.D. said seize the Ford.
Yeah, great.
- Yeah, yeah.
Like basically they're
funding all these things
that are destroying America.
- Yeah.
- And let's take the money.
- At least let's tax them,
'cause they're not
a real nonprofit.
- Mm-hmm.
- Like this huge nonprofit,
left-wing nonprofit
abuse in this country.
- Yeah.
All right, so if
it's not too late
to do something about big tech,
does it feel at least like
there was like this slow push
and then suddenly
it became very rapid
where right now it feels
like every day we wake up
and it's like, there's some
other crazy thing happening,
whether it's someone being
banned or the credit card stuff
that you're talking about or
something related to speech
or something where it seems
like, and everything we haven't,
we barely talked about. COVID,
we're just like every day,
some other crazy thing happens.
- Yeah.
- And it feels
like the algorithm's
feeding it to us.
Like, it doesn't feel
organic to me anymore
when I wake up every morning
and there's just some, you know,
and on Twitter experts say.
- Experts say.
- You already mentioned that,
that something else is fueling
like the craziness here.
- It's hard to know.
I mean, I agree with you,
it's just getting
crazier and crazier.
- Yeah.
- It feels
like a one-way ratchet.
How much is intentional
and manipulated
and designed for some
effect versus just,
this is the crazy consequence
of the world we live in,
it's very stagnant.
We have,
Eric Weinstein talks about
embedded growth obligations,
right?
- Mm-hmm.
- Like we have all
these expectations
that things just get better
and better in our society,
but they actually don't,
like these institutions
broke a long time ago,
but people I think are a
little bit behind the curve
in realizing it.
And so I think we're
careening off the cliff here,
like we're really close
and I think people feel that
something is really wrong,
but still the new cycle moves
and these momentary outrages
and everybody just
pays attention,
we go from acute
crisis to acute crisis,
who even knows what was
in the news two weeks ago.
Right, it's all just forgotten.
- Yeah.
- And I think
the short attention span
juxtaposed with the slow boil
of sort of losing the country,
losing these institutions,
I think we're in
a really bad spot.
- Is there a country
you can kind of point to
that is sort of doing it
in the broad sense, better?
Like, it seems like
every Western nation
is kind of crumbling
at the moment,
Australia they're attacking.
- Well, Australia is crazy.
Australia is crazy.
- And like, we don't see
that on our news here.
So if you say that to some,
I mean, I've brought this
up with family members,
you see what's going
on in Australia?
What's going on in Australia?
- Right.
- Like, oh,
actually, they've got
the army out there
hunting down people
for walking their dogs.
No, it can't be, then
you send them a video.
Oh, well that can't possibly be.
- It's just cherry picked, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But Australia, Canada, we're
seeing Western nations,
just nobody's really doing
it that well right now.
- Nobody's doing it that well.
And this is what I
realized is like,
there's no place else to go.
Like the United States is the
leader and if we lose it here,
I think Western Europe has
been gone for a long time,
it's just this pessimistic
managed decline.
- Is it Eastern Europe?
I mean, is it
countries like Poland.
- Sure.
- That seem to be sort of?
- Maybe, but I mean,
and Tucker Carlson goes
to Hungary or whatever,
and the internet, the left
lose their mind for a day.
(laughing)
- Right, right, right.
- I think maybe we have
some things to learn
or remember from
countries like that.
But there are also very
different countries, right?
There are small,
more homogenous,
more sort of poor
and manageable,
it's like the US is a
very different animal.
And so I, US is not
gonna become Hungary
and there are certain things,
ways in which we shouldn't.
So it's like, we
should be the US,
we should be the best version
of America.
- Mm-hmm.
- And a lot of that
is in the future
and a lot of that
is in the past.
And again, it's this
wisdom of knowing
what's good about our past,
like what do we as a people
believe in what's important,
what do we need to carry forward
and how should we navigate the
challenges of modern society?
And these are
questions that Congress
literally does not debate.
Like nobody talks about
this stuff in Congress.
The Senate is supposed
to be the greatest
debate hall in the world.
And it's not, it's just so.
- It's not on list even.
- It's on the list,
but to your point, it's
like, what is on the list?
- Right.
- Who is doing it well?
And I think if the
US falls, it's like,
there's really no global leader.
It's like, you could say China,
but obviously I think that's a
(chuckles)
horrible dystopian society.
That's not a charismatic.
- And yet there's this weird
love of China now from,
well, from the left
'cause I think they're enjoying
the destruction of America
in essence.
- Sure, but that's bad.
- Right.
- I'm not on that side.
- Yeah.
- I think
there's no good hope for freedom
as we sort of know it and have
cherished it over the decades
and the American experience,
two centuries of the American
experiment, like that,
there's nothing that says
that has to last forever.
This is what, I think people
just take it for granted,
like, oh, we live in America,
this is the best country.
You know, we're so exceptional.
And it's like, yeah,
I agree with all that,
but at the same time, if
you take it for granted
and you let your
institutions decay
government decay,
you end up in this place
where like nothing works.
And we live in this globalized
world where we're just,
it's homogenizing
and it doesn't work.
And I think the left
actually kind of likes
this in some weird way,
they get the stratified society
where you have the thin elite.
- Mm-hmm.
- At the top
and you hollow out the
middle-class and guess what?
The left gets to be
the elite, right?
- That's what I always say.
It's not that they
don't like the elites,
they just want their
people to be elites.
- They are the elite, right?
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- You go to the same schools,
you think the same
way, you run society,
you hollow out the middle-class
and then you have an
underclass, right?
People who are
perpetually on the Dole,
whether it's UBI or just
unlimited stimulus checks
or welfare as we know it,
that's a really bad
model for society.
It looks a lot more
like Brazil than the US
or how the US is
supposed to look.
And so I don't think it's over,
I think we can still actually
sort of arrest that decline,
but it starts by
talking about it,
it starts by waking people up.
You know, I tell people in these
Republican grassroots rooms
that I go to, like,
we've been playing defense
on the right for so long
that we're just out of
space to play defense.
Our backs are against the wall,
and so if we don't win in
2022 and 2024, it's over,
and you'd think that's
pessimistic and de-motivating,
but no, actually
it's like optimistic
because it means like,
recognize the strategy you've
been employing has failed,
recognize the stakes,
recognize the importance
of what we're fighting for
and go on offense.
Like let's go fight and win
because otherwise they're
gonna pack the Supreme Court,
they're gonna add new
states to the union,
they're going to
federalize elections,
everything will be woke,
there'll be Chinese style
social credit systems,
thought control.
Like in 10 years, this country
will look like Australia.
You'll have the
left-wing military
like hunting down people
for noncompliance,
like that can happen here.
And that's my message for
people, it can happen here.
- I was gonna ask you a
little bit more about Arizona,
but you are a politician now
and you had a hard
out for 50 minutes
'cause you got to go fundraise.
So you gave me a
nice closer there,
unless you want to bonus closer.
- Bonus closer.
- You want a bonus closer?
- Let's do it, bonus closer.
- Give me a bonus closer,
here we go.
Bring it.
- Look, I think,
I'm just really excited
to be running for office.
It's not something,
again, as discussed,
I didn't think 10 years
ago I'd be doing this.
I didn't think we
have the opportunity,
but president Trump came and
gave us a new lease on life.
I remind people who
are like really sad
that he's not in office
that okay, that sucks,
now we have an
incompetent president,
we have a wide open border,
inflation's going through
the roof, that's bad,
but remember that
without president Trump,
we'd be in year five of a
Hillary Clinton presidency.
And I think that
would be game over.
- Mm-hmm.
- And so consider
the gift that he,
even, if you thought
it was chaotic,
even if he didn't vote
for him the second time,
I disagree with you
and that's fine,
but he gave us this
new lease on life.
And I think the
Dems and the left,
they won't get it together,
like they don't understand
what's going on,
but the right,
if we can actually just
shed the Paul Ryanism,
if we can update, if
we can rebuild a party
that's pro working-class,
pro-American, pro-family,
we can actually still
have a good future.
Like I know it's possible.
And so that's why I get up every
day and I'm excited to run.
I don't think it's naive,
I think we can actually
build a better future.
And so that's what
I'm trying to do.
- You gave me two closers.
Not bad.
- Two closers.
- Not bad, not bad.
- Thank you, sir.
- Thanks Blake.
(tranquil ambient music)
If you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.